PUT IT RIGHT ON NET.
ITTHIS LEADS TO A GOOD SCORING
CHANCE.
IT IS BLOCKED.
IN.
10-0 RANGER LEAD -- -- RAANTA,
UNDER THE ARM.
AFTER SHESTERKIN MAKES THE
BREAKAWAY SAVE, MOTTE'SCOPP WAL.
IT HIT THEHE HAD A REBOUND OPPOA
GOAL BY MIKKO ZIBANEJAD AND A
PESCE THROWS IT OUT THERE FOR
TIGHT AVAILABILITY, HITS SVECHND
SHRUGS OFF, WATCH HIS MOVEMENT,
SI SHOT RIGHT ON.
GREAT STOPBY SHESTERKIN, DENYING
NIEDERREITER.
DEAD CENTER, SHESTERKIN'S STICK,
MAKES THE SAVE.
NOTHER STOP
AND ANOTHER.
THROWS IT TOWARDS THE
FILIP MAKES IT 3-0 THIRD GOAL
OF THE PLAYOFFS.
A THIS
BUILDING 10-2.
BRADY SKJEI'S SHOT AND IT
IN THE BACK OF SETH JARVIS AND
BR RIGHT SHOULDER OF
KOCHETKOV.
IT HITS OFF ONE ON
QUICKLY.
KOCH FORE-CHECK JUST JAMMI
CENTERS ONE OFF THE SIDE OF THE
BRADY SKJEI SENT IT KNEE OF
LINDGREN AND THROUGH THE LEGS O.
A CHANCE AND HE'S
SCHNEIDER, WORK EARLY IN THE
GAME AND GETS REWARDED LATE IN
THE GAME AS
2012.
THERE'S ONLY ONE PLACE TO GO,
OVER THE GLOVE.
IN